the Joe Rogan experience ever that's
that you have what you bombs and you
plate it for everybody
Tom's kind of have a half memory of that
yeah yeah yeah but I mean I played like
clip sir than anybody I don't think it
was good Tom you've ever sat in the back
of a room with that was not good
how about Sacramento that's the [ __ ]
worst the fun punchline with it what is
now it was called the laughs you know
the worst thing about a bomb what a bomb
on a Friday night is and that you bomb
on The Early Show and you can't believe
how hard you just bought like it's life
altering he'd bomb harder on The Late
Show oh and they're both sold out so
it's not like eight people like oh my
god
to the gills man what was the catalyst
the catalyst I mean he got me at because
I remember that I was like I am rethink
my life tonight like after you know
Jesus it was that bad but then what was
what started it would started the both
started the bomb was the opening joke
because I was just like by the way by
the way before you tell your opening
joke tom is great with feeling
uncomfortable in a moment and taking it
to the next level we're in Hawaii with
Russell Peters the one thing they say is
do not mention negative [ __ ] about the
Hawaiians Tom's opening joke do you
remember it and they said island life
slow I didn't know they were talking
about your metabolisms you guys did the
same [ __ ] in Australia first were lost
on base today luckily I ran into a
Japanese guy he pointed me out they know
everything about this base he's over
there drinking his own poo that's it
oh my god you got me for a fraction of a
second I was like no he didn't
I was like he's my disease drink his own
piss so wait how did your mom go in
Sacramento to the Sacramento bomb was
dirt it was the month after the month
after Hurricane Katrina
hmm so I opened with a joke I don't
remember the wording of it but it was
like how there were there's reports of
people raping people in the aftermath
and I was like yeah I was like I opened
I was just like you know nothing like a
seeing dead bodies float by that makes
me want to [ __ ] somebody you know and
then I just kind of like about like you
know dead people and I'd be like God and
it would eat so much [ __ ] there we go
you know you have to think like wise go
to my act now like I just go to like
yeah cuz it was like oh it was already
too late and I would bomb for the full
the fat you know funny thing is they
made in both shows yeah there's
something to this this is funny yeah and
nothing like seeing a dead person on a
TV floating by that [ __ ] that Club
lady Leslie you know like your new
feature and a Clem I remember she goes I
mean the bomb feels so bad then you're
sweating so hard you're like man that's
emotionally just taxing right you're
just like god damn right I walk offstage
and I run like indoor she goes I thought
you were supposed to be funny can't read
and I go what just like you're supposed
to do 25 you did 23 and I was like I've
[ __ ] all right and then like that's
the first show then the second show
literally is worse in an inconceivable
way is worse did you try to save that
joke again I try to open with it again
so hard eat it so hard that I'm middling
MCS like damn dude you [ __ ] suck he's
like he's like he's like you're like he
was just like it was that big deal
McClane
yeah he was like he was just like god
damn I've never seen anything like this
damn you felt like Big Lots
yeah it was my god and then the next day
I was like I don't know how I'm gonna do
this man and Burt Coast will give you
one piece of advice I go yeah just open
different I just do whatever you want
just open on a different joke I was like
all right man and at the time I swear to
you that [ __ ] first show Saturday by
the best set that I've ever had like
unbelievable set did the lady go oh okay
no no no she goes uh I I was I felt
redeemed right I [ __ ] destroy her
right and I what I mean like the emcee
is like Jesus because I've never seen a
turnaround like that I was like I'm like
it just feels like I I walk around and I
see her and I go like and she goes
what I didn't hear anything I go she
pretended like she didn't know [ __ ]
she kept coming up to me going you said
he was funny you brought him with you
and I trust me the best part about his
bomb was Tom you say oh man I lost man
oh wait I lost during the sweating all
those longer hair and comb it back so it
would be upright and as he bombed it
starts to fall wet
was soaking wet it was great like jump
in a pool like I was [ __ ] soaking wet
that feeling when you're eating [ __ ]
it's not like anything else on earth I
remember that I remember that like he
was up on stage and somebody yelled at
him like some lady he's like well you're
a [ __ ] dumb
cut you said that and the end of oh he's
like yeah they'll turn back
I remember him winning them back I was
like goddamn I used to have some some
quick co2 zon that ya favors
hey honey your mouth God made your mouth
for one thing and it's not talking
that's good god does that mean that's a
joke
[Applause]